- What the-
I think Josh is holding me back again.
- [Off-Screen Voice:] Hello, Stefon Diggs.
For years, you've angrily thrown tablets.
But today,
the tablet is going to throw you.
You have 5 seconds to simply say, I do not
blame anyone else for my problems.
Clock starts now.
- [Countdown:] Five, four...
- [Diggs:] I do not...
- [Countdown:] Three, two...
- [Diggs:] I can't do it.
- [Countdown:] One.
- Throw me.
- Well, they finally caught Kelce.
- My first professional death trap.
So blessed. Hahaha.
- Oh, God. Did they kill Belichick?
- That explains the last few seasons.
- [Off-Screen Voice:] Would you like to play a game?
- [All:] Yes!
- [Off-Screen Voice:] Sorry, I should clarify. Not a football game.
- [All:] No.
- [Kelce:] Boo!
- [Off-Screen Voice:] Aaron, you cheated Father Time with your injury recovery.
- Medicine is a lie, Mr. Pfizer.
- [Off-Screen Voice:] You can leave so long as you walk
across... Artificial Turf.
- [All:] AHHHH!
- OH, GOD. OH NO! Grass exists for a reason!
- YOU SICK FREAK!
- [Off-Screen Voice:] Bijan Robinson.
You made the mortal sin of having a headache during a game.
- Well, gee, sir, I sure am sorry
if I offended.
- [Off-Screen Voice:] Next to you is a razor.
Either cut off your own hand...
or your coach’s awesome new mustache.
- Please, Bijan. You're a running back.
You only need one hand.
- I'm so sorry, Coach.
(whimpers)
- AHHH, it hurts so bad!
Now I just look like any other billionaire’s son.
- [Off-Screen Voice:] Travis, you committed one of the worst sins,
distracting from the precious game.
- That is not blessed, bro.
- Kill me, but don’t get any blood on the Kelly Green jerseys.
They’re just too clean.
- Let him go.
- [Off-Screen Voice:] I will. You just have to tweet.
“Taylor's Era’s Tour is a great show,
but Beyonce's Renaissance Tour is an Experience.”
- I'm sorry, Tay.
I'm trying so hard to be a gentleman.
- [Off-Screen Voice:] I release you to the Swifties.
- [Swifities:] How dare you? / She’s gonna destroy you! / Through song!
- [Off-Screen Voice:] Puka. Cooper.
There can only be one of you.
- Oh, I don't think I'm going to kill Puka Nacua.
- Aw. Same to you, bro.
- [Off-Screen Voice:] THEN DEAL WITH: THE BLADES OF DEATH!
- Joke's on you. We're Rams.
We only know how to deal
with opposing fans.
- You'll never get us, bro. Life is too beautiful.
- [Off-Screen Voice:] You thought I was dead, but what is truly evil will never die.
- Just ask the Bills.
Game over.
- AHH!
- [Off-Screen Voice:] Dan Campbell, I'd like to play a game.
You were-
- Let's do it!! Ahhh!!!
- [Off-Screen Voice:] Wait, no, just use the key! This isn't THE test.
- I'm fired up, baby!
You saw us.
We saw you right back.
I don't need feet.
I need YARDS!